hey everybody and welcome to a
remorseful wild ride with steo there's
no other way to say it I've taken a
bunch of L's recently it's been weighing
me down and if I'm honest I wish I would
have recorded this podcast and put it up
sooner so that I could just get it off
my chest you know I think that the most
important thing in life is to
acknowledge when you've messed up when
you've come up short acknowledge it take
it on the chin accept the L and move
forward Having learned from it and
that's what I tried to do with this
episode um you know call me what you
will but uh somebody who hides from an L
I do not think I am and that's why this
episode is special and it's also the the
last one of the Year ladies and
Gentlemen people of the universe
so uh I hope you're enjoying your
holidays and I hope your year was great
I hope your next year is even better and
let's get into
it ladies and Gentlemen people of the
Universe I bring to you me and Scott
Randolph and your boy skinny Vinnie here
what's up everybody okay off camera
we've got Isaac and I'm just going to
start off by saying that um I've taken a
number of L's lately quite a few
yeah I uh been effectively hiding out in
uh Tennessee on um a ranch I've made my
time uh dedicated to to cutting wood
yeah wait you're out here because you're
taking L's and you're hiding out I mean
I don't know like it's I've been in a
little bit of a funk yeah really yeah
wow yeah okay so so we might as well
start with uh that's why you're out here
is that why I'm out
it's not why I'm out here but I'm out
here just feeling like man like I just
want to unplug and and I want to hide
out okay yeah that's good your obsession
to cutting firewood is really funny
every time Scott texts the group chat
hey dude can you confirm this we need
this confirmed and the only thing we get
back is a video of you chopping wood or
a photo of a stack of
wood yeah so um I mean let's start with
uh the the biggest L of them all it
would seem is my appearance on the Danny
Brown
podcast um I there well I had a couple
of offenses on there and uh I'm going to
completely cop to both of them um uh
first and foremost I offended I I
offended everybody but uh I don't I
don't know if I personally offended
Danny Brown himself um but while I was
on the podcast I asked Danny Brown
like what does he do on stage he
mentioned being on stage and I was like
oh yeah what he do on stage and people
were just generally outraged that I
would be on his show and not know like
what he does and uh you know I I don't
really have a defense for that um I mean
I did like a bunch of podcasts it was
probably close to 50 different podcasts
that I did and I've never heard of uh
like you know researching the show that
you're going on as being a thing but but
people were outraged so obviously I was
wrong I'm not going to defend it and
while I was on that podcast I went in on
video games in a way that just was was
super douchy didn't make even any sense
and uh and and was genuinely offensive
to everybody who loves video games see I
I missed the clip on what you said about
all the video game stuff I mean it was
there Clips on it how do you know like
people were offended not only are there
Clips on it there there are multiple
videos dedic like video essays dedicated
to uh how much of a fail I've just been
on podcasts in general um like one was
just dedicated alone to like how bad I
failed on the Danny Brown podcast and
for anybody who doesn't know Danny Brown
is a huge rapper he's also a a a video
game personality so it was like an extra
huge l
for me to not know anything about Danny
Brown and talk disparagingly of video
games yeah we don't like video game
people talk and you know what I'm done
with that because it's like hey if you
enjoy it then do it you know like I'm
certainly uh you know not accomplishing
much by by cutting firewood you know
like I I I do all kinds of stuff to
Waste My Time Imagine like just the
amount of time I spend uh scrolling
through social media and and watching
YouTube videos like everything that I've
ever said negative about video games
saying that it's a you know a waste of
time that it's it's like people sitting
on the sofa and just you know like I
mean there there's a million ways to
waste time and there's a million ways to
sit on the sofa and I'm guilty of all
kinds of them so I hereby promise to
never ever dis Spirit video games again
to to each their own whatever they enjoy
yeah but that's not enough what are you
going to do to make
it what are you going to do to make it
right are you going to get on like a
video game podcast play some video games
it absolutely occurred to me to get like
on some video game uh shows like I mean
there's a huge one I'm just guessing
that they're still very active Game
Grumps like I was on there and mind you
I was on there and and and said
disparaging things about video games
years ago and uh I mean it was just it
was just kind of a different tone and it
was kind of fun and light whereas on the
Danny Brown podcast I don't know I was
just burned out I was just burned out by
that point and uh I think let's get you
on a twitch and let's get you like an
Activision account let's get you to play
some
games you know we can get you on Call Of
Duty Modern Warfare 3 we can reach out
to them see if they want to give you a
steo skin I there's a lot of ways back
to the gamer Community I don't know what
a skin is but uh but I do want to make
it up to the gamer Community all right
so let's move on to to the
next and uh is it hot in
here um what
uh there was there was a and this
particularly hurt because there's a um a
YouTube channel that I watch a lot of
it's called too lazy to try I think it's
spelled with the number
two uh too lazy to try and there's uh I
I think they got like um um like more
views than usual on their video essay
about how uh I've just it says sto's
podcast appearances are a
mess and um the like I mean the tons of
viewership on it and uh
yeah 209,000 views so here's the thing
um there there are personalities out
there who have been known to like send
copyright claims try to like shut down
channels like I'm not that guy not only
am I happy for too lazy to try to have
his his video so I'm not going to
challenge anything I'm sitting here
promoting it and and I like it it was
going to hurt my feelings I know
probably too much to actually watch it
like I'm I'm asking you guys did you
watch it I did not my it's full I
watched the whole thing oh that's your
time okay so so Isaac might need a mic
right now do you do you agree with with
everything that that was said or do you
think that it was a little too much well
what did they say and maybe what what
did they say on there well I mean in in
general there was a critique of you not
knowing about who Danny Brown was and
then obviously the video game critique
and the video game yeah they brought
light to your appearance on the Adam
fredland show what was the the criticism
there uh the criticism there was that
you you weren't engaging with them too
much and you were um really enjoying
your time with the fume okay while they
bantered back and forth I mean that one
like I'm not going to necessarily push
back on that one but they have their own
like kind of a thing yeah their own
little stick yeah like the Adam fredin
show they were doing their kind of thing
and like for me me to try to like steer
that ship it just wasn't going to happen
so I just kind of let them do their
thing I I don't know that that was uh an
offense what number of pod like how many
podcasts did you do during that time at
least 40 so is there like on the next
thing that you're promoting is there
like a number that you're like I
probably shouldn't go over yeah maybe 24
in two weeks yeah me okay so what what
are the are there any more L's just kind
of generally over promoting The Bucket
List I'm guessing yeah just like kind of
driving the conversation back to
theck and I did watch the beginning of
the video and he was like Hey you know
he's out there promoting his thing and
and he said that uh by by making my
comedy specials multi media and like
jackass style of uh of stuff that that
that's a good call um and I am proud of
it dude like the bucket you should be
it's super epic thanks for that Benny
and I do agree the bucket list is super
sick and I also feel very strongly about
how super sick Shopify is Shopify is
sponsoring this episode and let me tell
you why I love them because they bring
into one easy to use interface every
possible facet of online business that
could possibly exist and I've had
websites since before a lot of you guys
were born and I've had every kind of
website along the way and only with
Shopify is it so easy to get started
building a website to get started
building a business and to be able to
integrate everything frankly if your
website isn't using Shopify then it's
going to be a lot harder for you to
incorporate other elements of business
that's all anything anybody wants is for
your website to be Shopify for your
eCommerce Hub to run with Shopify
because it's the easiest it's the best
it is the gold standard of e-commerce
and I'm telling you I am an e-commerce
guy and I love it I stand by it and
Shopify loves me and they love the
listeners of the Wild Ride podcast
that's why you guys can get a $1 per
month trial period at shopify.com
sto be careful to make sure it's all
lowercase
shopify.com
sto for that $1 per month trial period
it doesn't get any more risk-free than
that and whatever stage your business is
is in if you're just starting to build a
website or if you already have a huge
business and you want to scale up
doesn't matter what level you're at
Shopify is your answer so one more time
go to shopify.com
ssto to get the $1 per month trial
period it and let's get back to it well
what else are you supposed to do I mean
are people ripping on Robert Downey Jr
when they're going around promoting Iron
Man through you know what I mean it's
like how come there's no there's only
like YouTube channels that bash like
comedians that are doing [__] and like
are there ones that like bash you know
Scarlett Johanson for promoting well I
mean it's interesting man it calls to
mind what I what I brought up with
Michael Chandler the the UFC fighter
about how there 's no other sport other
than the
UFC where people are like dude you suck
man you just trying to win you know like
any other sport if you win that's a good
thing but in the UFC you have to both
win and be entertaining be wildly
entertaining and and uh Drive the fans
crazy with all the excitement and and
like being uh you know an an Entertainer
and a businessman you get kind of the
same thing like oh dude you're a
businessman you're trying to make money
yeah you like what do you think business
is like business is is uh an exercise
and trying to make money but uh but
clearly I'm um you know back at these
Crossroads of like like what am I a
businessman or am I Entertainer you know
and I really really like have just want
to just go back to just giving people
entertainment that they enjoy well now's
probably a good time to cut to an ad
read
if no but like that's the thing people
I've I've said this before that like
podcast anybody watch anybody's
complaining about ad reads on a podcast
like just doesn't watch podcasts like
I'm never GNA feel bad about and plus
like Vinnie you put chapters in there so
they can skip ahead to that if you want
you don't want to listen y That's
exactly doing uh doing chapters we we
should announce that Vinnie is uh the
main editor yeah and the other thing
that I've been been seeing is like
sometimes what YouTube will do is like
right after an ad read it will be
YouTube ads so it's like don't we
disable those I no one told me to
disable you oh yeah I think disable the
the mid rolls the mid rolls okay yeah I
don't think I don't think we ever wanted
to have mid rolls okay uh and for the
record um I wasn't the one nose
breathing on the last podcast do we know
did we ever find out who it was it was
me it was you it was me were like dude
who's nose breathing yeah man that's
Brave of you guys to to be able to check
out the comments dude yeah it's uh it
gets pretty rough sometimes but it's
also yeah but it's also it's like with
this nose breathing thing I could be
like okay maybe I uh should just hold my
mic like this so it's like I learned
something it's constructive criticism
there is there's all kinds of
constructive criticism in there and I
maintain that when something
particularly hurts it's because I agree
with it yeah and if I agree with it then
then it's something that I need to
address definitely like one comment was
if you took a shot every time Vinnie
said for sure you'd be wasted by the
time so it's like okay it's constructive
criticism now I like I'm kind of aware
of what I'm saying it's tough I mean
it's like you got this you know role
speaking to people and it just so
happens you're speaking to like 200,000
people like [__] it's not like you're
standing up in front of a class of 40
people I tell you like it irks the hell
out of me when people say you know a
million times or if they say like a
million times see I say the same thing
but also it's like when I'm watching
back some stuff I'm one of those people
who say like a lot or also you know so
it's like it's a tough one yeah it's a
tough one and and it's when you're in a
situation where it's you acknowledge it
in your mind that it's bothering you and
then like you start keeping count and
you're like yeah yeah yeah a thing that
really bothers me is like cussing I wish
I can just not cuss I well so far we've
been pretty good yeah but you know to to
like describe something where people are
and I'm going to say like you know
because it's but you know I wish I
didn't all right you're doing
great what happened I just blacked out
there for a second you're doing a really
good job so you went to UFC fights about
a month ago um the uh the the the L
subject have we covered everything and
and um like how do I redeem myself like
with well well for the for the gaming
one I think we already established that
the gaming one like I just hope that and
I'm gonna say this whenever that comes
up like I know what to do with the
gaming one you know I I I could reach
out to Danny Brown that'd probably be a
good idea that's a good idea and look
dude there's been times in the past
where you've we've taken some L's and
you've done really well at like giving
back to the fans and the people of like
oh dude at the end of the episode let's
give away free shirts let's give you
know it's like so I don't really see the
big deal of like I mean here's the thing
is that I I know that I could pretend I
never saw it I could pretend it doesn't
bother me I could go through life and
it's probably not going to Define my
existence but I think that by letting it
affect me by drawing attention to it and
by like expressing the desire to to grow
and and and make things right I think
that that that's what life is about
absolutely you know acknowledging when
you came up short and take
accountability for it take the L take
you got to stand up and take the L
acknowledge it and try to fix it and try
to move on in a better way yeah yeah I
think people in the comment sections
like want resistance they want you to
like argue back or fight it it's like
but what are they going to say when
you're like yeah you're right right [__]
what can I do about it okay cool can we
move on um are there any other uh like
uh hit pieces that we should
promote I I remember seeing one that
that was I think just uh devoted to steo
fail on the Danny Brown they made a
whole video just about how much of a
fail that was on but I think that we've
probably exhausted that uh if we want to
just you know shout out that one video
what I'm very interested in is you you
didn't tell me what happened with Kid
Rock the whole Kid Rock situation that
that is technically another L okay well
then great
transition okay so um I was in uh
Madison Square Gardens for uh the UFC
295 love the UFC every time um at the
beginning of the main
card Donald Trump walks in with Kid Rock
and Dana White and it's it's just like
wow how ecstatic was that crowd dude
they they were they were wild and and uh
they're they're it's it's it's it's
crazy like I feel like in the past maybe
it'd be like a little bit mixed but the
UFC I think it's a good call for Donald
Trump to be showing up at UFC fights
because it is
just
overwhelmingly in uh in favor of him
it's it's uh I believe that it's helping
him but in any case of course I have a I
have a history with Kid Rock I made a
video one of the most viewed videos on
my main YouTube channel is called
celebrities I did cocaine with and
um I haven't seen Kid Rock since like in
in all the in all these years and um and
I go to the bathroom you know we go to
the bathroom in like this special area
and and uh Kid Rock is in the bathroom
as I'm waiting to go into the bathroom
he comes out and I'm like yeah what's up
dude you know like I'm just excited
farth this thing from my mind mind is
that video and uh and he's like yo why'd
you do me like
that that's the first thing he said to
you yeah some I mean sound like that
he's just like yeah man like why why'd
you do me like that and I was just think
like I I was I was stumped I was like oh
H he's like yeah I mean he was he was by
the way everything in the video 100%
true you know 100% true like I don't
have any issue with that but like like
but why why' you do that you know and I
wish that I could have that uh
that encounter to do over again because
uh the obvious answer is that there was
no uh Revelation there you know like Kid
Rock's like singing about
enjoying you know like and and
furthermore there it was like I just
wish I would have said but bro like
there was no like Secrets Revealed and
it was the most
glorious like epic like celebration of
rock stardom at the highest level like I
was I just couldn't imagine that you'd
be bummed on like how glorious of a
story that was what year was that that
was um it was New Year's Eve
when
203 turned into 2000 sorry 2004 turned
into 200 19 years ago yeah yeah yeah but
in any case like uh it was it was you
know like we we went we stood there and
talked a little bit longer than that I
let him know that uh that I'm uh out
here in Tennessee he was stoked about
that he was like man I just like I'm
really just glad that you're doing well
he said really nice oh so it ended on a
good note yeah yeah it wasn't like it
wasn't like uh you know it was cool it
wasn't Kid Rock now has beef with st no
no no it was definitely not kid Rock now
has beef and um he was just cool man and
and he's he was like oh dude one thing
has really changed since uh since I saw
you li he goes now I'm
rich really I was like I was like
actually yeah Kid Rock You Know actually
Bob you had that covered back
theno and then he went in the stall and
did a a
b um it was it was it was uh but but it
it it was an L I mean he he called me
out and I was just like man
H man with all the L's on this episode I
just got to stop and give myself a W for
all the times I've taken blueo tablets
and then gotten into the sack with my
lady blueo tablets same active
ingredient as Viagra and sealas except
they're delicious they're chewable and
they only cost a fraction of the price
if you're wondering might it be a lot of
fun to take a blue Cho tablet and then
get down with my significant other I can
assure you it is a ton of fun and a
major W every time I do it and when my
lady sees my blue tongue I stick it out
she knows it's on she's she cheers
because it's on you guys can get an
entire month supply completely for free
if you go to Blue Cho . and use the
promo code steo you you do that you
consult with the medical provider online
take care of your prescription and boom
an entire month supply of blue Cho
tablets is on its way to you absolutely
for free all you have to pay is five
bucks for shipping I mean that's got to
be one of the greatest deals that we've
ever been able to offer our listeners so
one more time go to bluechew.com and use
use the promo code steo to get that
entire month supply of blueo tablets
completely for free all you pay is five
bucks for shipping you can thank me
later now let's get back to
it like I'm I'm I'm bummed that he was
bummed and I was like dude I would just
never like mean mean to bum you out you
know like I I just thought that whole
video was uh was just fun and ridiculous
and you know but in any case doesn't he
have a he has like a White House house
out
here I don't doubt it he has a replica
of inside of his White House oh wow
that's his Nashville house right
there how gnarly is that I mean what I
heard is that uh like every land owner
or property owner like in like in his
vicinity he's like buying up all of
their and he's doing deals where like
he'll he'll buy somebody's property but
that but they're they can just live on
it as usual for the rest of their
natural life that's what Brad Pit did
and that's what they did with the
Playboy Mansion oh really didn't didn't
Hugh Hefner sell the Playboy Mansion to
somebody who' let him live there oh
until he died yeah for the rest of his
natural life that's a thing but yeah Kid
Rock is baller dude how far is he from
from you I have no idea I didn't ask him
as a dress
dog clearly I can't be trusted with any
information
yeah a YouTube video on his
address right um but yeah when so he
rolled in with he rolled in with Trump
he rolled in with Trump and and it was
just during the fights like I just have
a thing where I have to pee all the time
like I go to the bathroom like because
you drink so much [__] coffee yeah
well but all right so I think on the
list is talking about Trump shout out to
Kid Rock shout out to uh just for being
cool man and um I never meant to bum him
out and like I consider him uh and and
particularly that story to be glorious
and yeah it's pretty epic alltime
rockar like highest level of rock for
sure yeah um so yeah Trump was uh was
there did you talk to Trump I did not
talk to Trump all right so here we are
if if okay well here's the thing like uh
I I I talked about this you know on that
disastrous promotional
run a couple times uh that that that one
night just out of curiosity I Googled
like what are the Vagas odds of Donald
Trump becoming president again and it
was like the the most likely
scenario like wait what and then like
okay presidential election odds he's
like
uh okay the his legal Wes are not
slowing him down he's favored to win
Donald Trump becoming
president uh plus there's a 45% chance
of Donald Trump becoming president and
the
33.3% chance of Biden becoming president
now look up the Vegas odds of Donald
Trump versus Biden what of the Vegas
odds it's going to be Trump versus
Biden in uh
2024 like this is insane like
there's there's uh it's just like it's a
foregone conclusion well that Trump's
gonna win well no that that it's that
it's GNA be Biden versus Trump and uh in
the the actual as the
primaries like I mean then why are they
even having a race for like the other
why are they having a race for for
runner up yeah it's like I think it's
Trump's in court and he's beating
everybody that's even debating like
Vivic Remis Swami he's not even showing
up he's not even showing up and it's is
becoming more and more popular it's uh
so 41% probability that Donald Trump's
going to win um I mean here's the thing
if it comes down to Trump versus Biden
and you have a gun your head who do you
vote for I mean I I
don't I'm not going to try to alienate
anybody who has strong political beliefs
I will just say this that
even people who are not fans of Donald
Trump even people who do not want Donald
Trump to be the
president I would not be surprised if
the majority of them would rather Donald
Trump be president then Biden but
Biden's pretty bad I
mean I mean dude like the gaffs and he
can't even talk right he's shaking
people's hands who aren't there is this
where he falls but why is is that the
choice that's the problem that's yeah
that's the like why can't we come up
with anything better than than you know
and and and I I'll say this that uh this
like you know I feel like Biden is just
clamoring to get us into a war but he's
not even
functioning like he's not like
calculating a war he he doesn't have the
ability I I I don't know and and one
could argue that the that the the
president is just like a you know like a
I mean Jesus Christ dude say it looks
like my grandpa that had had Alzheimer's
towards the end I mean anybody listening
we're basically watching a montage of
pres President Biden just falling down
falling off bikes falling on stairs yeah
I mean I think the the best bet that's
not even that bad like I can I mean
wasn't one of the presidents in a
wheelchair the whole time FDR yeah I
mean like like like who cares if the guy
doesn't have good balance the problem is
that he can't talk well he doesn't he
doesn't have good balance because he's
like deteriorating you know FDR had
Polio was it FDR I mean I don't know
[__] about President's but I don't know
and then we don't need to become a a
political show but uh I just think that
it is it is really really something that
that we're looking at Biden versus Trump
I mean I don't like Nome but like Nome
would be the Democratic best bet or RFK
but the Democrats don't even like RFK D
they they don't have anybody it's it's a
moot point there's nobody yeah it's it's
insane okay so what what's next well I I
think uh yeah I mean you want to talk
about that news okay but we got to talk
about our boy Vinnie over here yeah
let's do it we've we've we've mentioned
that
Vinnie has gotten crushed a lot of beef
been an absolute beef Crusher mhm and
now he's going to be a uh crushing the
same beef for the rest of my life one
dude I am one gas dud one gas guy
yeah yeah and and I'm happy about it
going to be a one gash guy a one gash
guy yeah and uh and uh and Vinnie's the
main editor we might as well just say
producer yeah I me over here producing
his ass off yeah it's on my
IMDb did you create your own IMDb page
no I did not came up it just came up you
have an IMD oh no I have an IMDb yeah
that's does it say skinny Vinnie uh no
it has my name okay and and you're
getting married uh yes I'm getting
married no yeah so uh next month January
is the big day I'm I'm happy um why I
why are you getting married on a Monday
it's the first wedding I've ever been to
that's getting married on a Monday so
because we're doing the whole uh the the
White Chapel thing and on the weekends
they're just so booked you're literally
like standing in line to get married
because those Elvis impersonators are
just so C rushing it you're so in demand
yeah yeah you're getting married by an
Elvis impersonator yes I am at the White
Chapel at the White Chapel the the mini
White Chapel and then you're having a
reception at a h a house afterwards yes
at a a pretty sick house looking over
the strip and are you nervous about
getting married um no I'm not nervous
about getting married I'm just
uh I'm just I don't like uh like the the
whole like standing at the the the altar
that in front of everybody that kind of
like what about that doing the vows just
no just yeah just getting like super
vulnerable have you have you already
written your vows uh a little bit um man
I I'll get myself in in trouble like uh
I I when you look at the
statistically the the you're getting
yourself in trouble
already
the statistical odds of of
marriages not ending in divorce how many
what what are the what's what percentage
of marriage end and divorce
80%
73 boy of third marriages are dissolved
uh 67 of second
marriages does that mean that
the all right they say statistically the
more you spend on the wedding the less
time you're going to be married for you
ever heard that I have
not good
shap is going to fuing stay together
forever yeah see I I I always wanted
like the big wedding but then like I
realized how much [__] money it cost
me yeah it's expensive to get marri no
I'm good dude like it's crazy man like
everything's expensive dude um so I my
point being that with the divorce
statistics being so staggered inly not
in favor of marriages working out like
it makes the the wedding vows seem
like
disingenuous right like it's just like
okay you know and I'm not even I think
that my Approach by staying engaged for
so long like when I get married like I
have no not that I had question in my
mind before but I think that by taking
time and you want to know know that
you're doing something right or you
should just not bother doing it at all
and that's how I feel about coffee which
is why I love AO press so much turns out
drip coffee is for
losers and Aero press is the way to go
it's not French Press it's Aero press
and dude like uh they have these World
Championship competitions where Baristas
like compete over making coffee and it's
all about AER press by the way they have
55,000 fstar reviews on like the
internet might be the best reviewed
product that we've ever had and now for
those who are not able to see oh boy oh
boy I got a fire I
got oh
boy all right for those of you who can't
see I just took a cast iron skillet out
of the fireplace and badly poured it
into my arrow press and now comes the
satisfying
plunge listen to
this and that ladies and gentlemen is
how you make coffee like a real badass
so you want to try this you go to arop
press.com SLO that's a e o p
s.com steo for up to 20% off your order
and Christmas might be over but how
about buying yourself this gift you
coffee lover you one more time it's
aerop
press.com Diva for up to 20% off your
arrow press stop dripping start pressing
and let's get back to
it you know really being sure like look
before you leap you know like I'm not
even like [__] on on my odds I'm
just saying that in the totality the big
picture of it numers like when people
get divorced and then they play back the
footage of them reading their vows it's
just like eh you know know mhm so I
don't know like I I just want to give
give my vows a lot of thought and do
that you know the um Neil Donald Walsh
in conversations with God book two or or
book three just [__] on marriage so bad
yeah but I feel like he was married yeah
and he got married after that oh really
he got remarried after that and he wrote
vows and in like a particular way that
that uh that worked but it was just like
the nature of the universe like
everything is energy and everything is
always constantly changing like that's
just that's physics that's that's
everything nothing stays the same that's
the universe so how can you speak to
speak now about how you're going to feel
later when everything changes that's
just like the fundamental problem yeah
but isn't that supposed to like the
whole thing about love and marriage like
having to fight for to keep that
feeling right I mean the the definition
of a perfect marriage is to imperfect
people who refuse to give up on each
other and I love that I love that too I
love that too but what what then like
Steve what denomination are you going to
get married under I mean denomination
since what what what do you mean I mean
like uh like Catholic Christian
spiritual are going have the srf like
what's the do you have to have a
denomination well is there going to be a
priest Mar you is going to be a buddy
like I don't know how that works
somebody get me a
Satanist you want a say a Satanist to
give you your vows I bet I bet honey
like Vinnie what's like like is I mean
that's why I asked you two if you guys
were a um but you're Italian so is it
like a Catholic thing or no I mean non-
denominal non denominational wedding is
a ceremony that doesn't necessarily have
a religious tone but it can include some
religious references if the couple so
chooses so you're going to have a
Satanist yours I mean I don't know like
I I don't need to to like go out of my
way to to rub people the wrong way I
mean I I would like like I choose
Satanism but you know uh I don't know
yeah I mean I think that rubbed people
the wrong way but uh what is the
definition of Satanism okay I've my own
my own definition of Satanism and the
only reason why I even like get a kick
out of it the worship of Satan right I
mean it's it's it's a farce dude nobody
who identifies as a Satanist even
believes in Satan I don't think what it
is is to me the idea of Heaven being
exclusive to anybody who doesn't believe
a certain thing is uh is is not cool man
I mean I grew up my best friend Abdullah
a Muslim like what am I going to
subscribe to some kind of belief that
I'm going to go to a heaven that
Abdullah is not allowed in like that's
the problem for me the problem is If
Heaven's all that it's cracked up to be
I would love to check it out but not
without everybody who I love of all
different beliefs simple you know so I I
don't I don't have an I don't have an
interest in a heaven that does not
include all of my loved ones and by the
measure of religions the way I see it
that means I'm going to hell because I
don't want to accept something that
excludes my loved ones so that means I'm
going to hell so I better start trying
to get cool Satan now because I'm going
to hell because I'm not going I don't
want to be in heaven without my friends
yeah I think though that like organized
religions are the only one that comes up
with those types of Heaven like when
when you get I but I I was listening to
like a nde on this girl who went to
church three times a week she was a
Catholic she was like 60 years old she
died and she and she went to heaven and
she's like dude it's it's not like
anything that you read in the Bible it's
exactly what you're describing and so
she came back just imagine like a
60-year-old woman who went to church
three times a week to pray she's like I
stopped going to church because it's not
what it is in the Bible so I mean that's
the thing is that like again the
universe is all energy and it's always
changing and it's there's only one thing
mhm you know it's like a drop of water
is is also the ocean you can't separate
a drop of water from the ocean because
it's one thing and so we're all little
drops of water in a big ocean and we're
all the same ocean so the idea that
there's any separation is stupid yeah
they said the wave can't say it's the
ocean but the the ocean can say it's the
wave say that again the the the wave
cannot say it's the entire ocean but the
ocean can say it is the wave okay oo I
like that I think that's like you know
we can't say we're God but we're a part
of it but God can say it's us yeah so
there's that oh I like that yeah I you
know I remember like my first week of
college like in between beers and vodka
and weed I was like like nothing to do
with my classes but I had this deep
thought we are all cells in the body of
God and I wrote like this whole essay
about it and like brought it to my
teacher my teacher was like interesting
it's got nothing to do with
it dude when was the first time you did
acid how old were you uh 16 and when you
scored it were you nervous to do it or
were you I I was and
um if I recall correctly I bought the
asset said kept it in my wallet cuz I
was saving it for when I was going to
take it and like I think that just it
being in my wallet like completely
ruined the uh I've heard that before it
just it just took all the power out of
it you're supposed to keep it in like
tin foil if you're going to put it you
remember what design it on it I I think
I
took maybe I took like a half a hit and
it was like didn't have anything in it I
think I took it and it didn't work then
I went to the Grateful Dead concert and
took a full one that like
absolutely that was when like I was
trying to fall asleep for school because
I had school the next day and there were
three of me laying in the bed yeah and I
was like trying not to disturb the the
me that was on on on this side or or the
me that was on the other side I was in
the middle and it was like all three of
us are trying to sleep here like but
were you the kind of guy that like once
he did a new drug like were you the kind
of guy who would get nervous about or
you're like nah give it let me try it or
were you like like my hands are getting
clammy just [__] thinking about doing
drugs and I haven't you know I was just
very excited to try whatever I can get
my cuz you shot up acid yeah and like
you weren't you weren't nervous about no
no not at all I at that point when I
when I did shoot up acid it was my my
motto was like if I could rig it I could
dig it so it's like oh my God anything
that I could put in a needle I would and
I just it it it was really gnarly what I
didn't do it again but it was like a
hell of an experience what was it it was
just instant like you know how so it
takes a little bit of time to to kick in
when you eat it it was just snap a
finger how many doses did you take I
don't know the the mill milliliters but
it was uh you took a tab you cooked it
up and you no no no no we had the liquid
LSD we had the liquid LSD that we got
from Silk Road
Sil and you bought it through Bitcoin
with Bitcoin when Bitcoin was $100 and
you wow yeah how much is asset on the
Silk Road at that time okay wait a
second so you had Bitcoin when it was
worth a hundred
bucks and what did you sell it at um we
didn't sell we would use it to buy drugs
off office how many Bitcoin you think
you spend oh
yeah oh dude we were spending a lot a
Bitcoin yeah a lot because we lived in
the middle of Vermont so it's like we
didn't really have drug dealers anywhere
so it's like that we would just order a
bunch drugs and come straight to our
door was just reliable as hell super it
was like Amazon it was like Amazon
festar reviews you know if they had good
reviews you know that they wouldn't rob
you for your money what' you buy on
there everything
like give me an example of something you
bought on there heroin liquid LSD
powdered Xanax is good
bro the the stuff that I've gotten off
silic road was probably the best stuff
I've ever done in my life whoa no joke
yeah
straight to your doorstep right but but
like let's say marijuana it just it has
a powerful smell like what do they do
about that we never ordered marijuana I
mean dude at that time I wasn't worried
about smoking weed I all my interest was
just [__] right okay so what so uh
does heroin not have like a a smell no I
mean it does if you take it out of the
package but like if you wrap it up
pretty good so so Silk Road had like
like packing standards to make sure that
yeah yeah really would they put would
would would you order like a like an
ounce of heroin and it shows up in like
a big gigantic box where it's hidden in
the middle no it would uh a lot of the
times it would be in like candy packages
and it would be like a box full of
different things of candy and then like
would there would there be like a a
little uh note on your account be like
it's in the Reese's yeah yeah yeah
really you weren't worried about like
the F it says the FBI shuts down Silk
Road like you weren't worried about them
know you had an account no dude I was
what was your username on there every
every YouTube video about Sil Gro is the
greatest video out there dude it was
crazy you could you could get anything
you wanted from the black market on
silkroad it was super gnarly and wasn't
it like uh that that they promised that
they didn't keep anybody's information
but in fact they totally did and then
the FBI had like the guy's laptop with
like every single person's name and
address you see that movie on the Silk
Road I tried to watch the movie with the
actors and I just couldn't do it but uh
I watched every documentary on YouTube
see uh Vinnie how do you how did you log
into the Silk Road what do you you had
to use a a a tour a tour yeah a torrent
a torrent yeah not not I think a torrent
is different than
tour I think I I I'm not sure see I
wasn't the The Tech Guy The Tech Guy was
like my best friend he was the one that
had all the Bitcoin he was the one that
do that but he passed away did you see
things you can buy cuz I've heard you
could like hire a hit hit man you could
hire you saw all that for purchase how
much is it to like hire a hit I don't
remember I wasn't really didn't and then
the guy the silr guy was like hiring a
hit I don't know he ended up getting
busted at like a a library he ended up
getting busted for trying to hire a hit
oh I don't know yeah that's wild dude
sentence Tois I'm sitting there
obviously my my retention is not that
great if I watched every video about it
but I swear I I I loved every video I
watched like eventually when when Silk
Road got taken down they they started
Silk Road 2 and then that got taken down
and then it was a Pandora's market and
that was a big one people are buying
drugs on like Craigslist right so like
if you need c you got to go Mur for H he
targeted five people and murder for high
the guy ended up in like a rocking a
hard spot situation where like if he
didn't um like draw a hard line and and
kill some people then everyone else is
going to take advantage of him yeah poor
poor
guy
yeah God decision's
decision so Vinnie when people go into
like your sober living or something like
I it's crazy to me that people are
buying like heroin off Craigslist and
what they're searching for is like I
need I'm looking for a roofer For Hire
no no so if if you're looking for heroin
it's called Roofing tar like you search
up roofing tar on Craigslist really or
xanax you you uh ladders um what yeah
Ladders because of xanx bar looks like a
little mini ladder and then uh for
crystal meth it was
a uh window window something and so what
you go to like hiring on Craigslist and
because it's called glass yeah yeah
glass yeah and uh um no you don't look
not for hire for sale in the for sale
stuff Isaac can you do that I don't know
if it's still a thing anymore but I
because that's when I was in when I
first came don't do that dude I don't
need my house like Jord no no but you're
just hiring a
painter so you're looking for a roofer
For Hire right so like none of these are
you know no no you'd be able to tell um
cuz before I came to La I never heard of
it like like the only thing that I was
like order an escort off Craigslist in
Connecticut yeah but uh I was when I
went to my first rehab in La I heard
somebody talk about it and when I got
kicked out I was like yeah let me try it
and that's what I was doing because I
didn't know anybody you were looking for
heroin yeah on Craigslist yeah and you
would actually scor a bunch yeah I
scored it a bunch of times it wasn't as
good as silk road no no and plus the
West Coast stuff is way shittier than
the East Coast stuff okay so uh you get
China White on one coast and black tar
on the other yeah I mean so black tar
would be on the west coast um East Coast
you'd get lucky if you found China White
but it was mostly it would be like this
root beer color you know um but it was a
it was a
powder how how many times did you o I
have 15
15 how how do you know I've woken up
next to EMTs 15 times three of them I
was pronounced dead 15 three times what
three of them I was pronounced dead wow
you've been dead dude we always just
keep going deeper and deeper he watch
out guys I'm I'm just trying to do a
little fire management right here
throwing throwing logs on the fire [__]
all right well what's next on the list
I'm excited about this one I think it's
uh the affiliate marketing program can
we talk about that these are all the
things that um you can find them on your
website I mean here's the thing dude
like uh the um we're back to the thing
where it's like oh dude you're
businessman trying to make money you
know like that that's kind of the the
jam that we find you make 30 cents when
somebody orders something hey I get it I
get it and
acknowledging that by banging everybody
body over the head with buy this buy
that give me your money for this give me
it's actually a much uh softer and less
abrasive approach to being
entrepreneurial by just talking about
things that I cannot live without yeah
can can can you go to the sto.com and
then see where they are because I would
actually be interested maybe you can
pick a couple and choose why you chose
these just write uh go up uh underneath
the products
nope go down um I mean don't even worry
about it because it's in my Instagram oh
ste's favorite products is also I mean
you have a Contigo right here can you
explain just maybe two or three of them
why you like them everything is every
episode of the wild rart podcast I
always have my Contigo I swear by it I
love it it's because you can't spill and
when you want to take a sip you push the
button like I love it um people are ask
me what's my biggest regret in in life
and it's 100% that I went for so many
years without
flossing uh because by not flossing I
ended up with like food stuck between my
teeth and then that food rots and then
you get this bacteria in your mouth that
you yourself cannot smell but everybody
that you talk to can absolutely smell it
and nobody will ever say yo you got bad
breath because that's just our Society
is structured that way so now because of
that bacteria like my like my my gums
went to hell and and and with all my
fake teeth like I've got more areas that
can catch like food that can rot so for
me like flossing is huge I've got my
charcoal mint floss on there and my
water pick dude that's just that's the
water pck blasts it's just like pressure
cleaning kind of you blast out all the
like the loose it's amazing like when
you use a water pick you think you're
fine you can do this brush your teeth
brush your teeth completely where you
feel like you're totally clean and then
as an afterthought use the water pick
where you blast the water between your
teeth and all of this food will come out
you'll be like oh my God I thought I had
it clean the water picks on this yeah
big time right there it's the the the 25
bucks waterpick cordless like travel
water pick and you just blast you're
like oh my God all that food that I just
blasted out with the water pick was was
jammed in between my teeth and it was
going to rot and turn into this yeah
iosis I remember in
1996 I was on this road trip with this
guy and he goes dude your breath smells
like something crawled behind your teeth
and died and uh in hindsight like that's
almost exactly what happened just it
died first
yeah what what I'm curious about this
road trip you took in 96 um it was uh my
first ever sponsor one that that never
even gets mentioned because that it was
not a company that was like hip to
skating it was the first company that
gave me a t-shirt it's called it was
called
bezo and uh they like wait wait if
you're going to give me a t-shirt I'm
going to ride from Florida to New
Mexico wow the the the guy they put in
charge who the rad guy that they hired
to run it was this guy Jim cage and he
had a like a just a random Porsche that
he had to pick up I forget how do you
spell bzo it was b i z o it was called
Extreme Wear for the
planet how did he find
you yeah yeah there you go type in Ste
type in steo see if he's in any articles
look at
that oh
[__] that's like raver gear God D I kind
of want to buy this vintage bezo stuff
then they went on to make shoes they
were the worst shoes are you in any like
uh articles or anything uh I mean I I
would imagine that I probably am
remember they hired these Surfers and P
they paid the Surfers like uh I think 30
grand for like their deals and I was
just like oh my God those guys are
rich um but yeah that's so funny all
right gentlemen I think uh I want to
wrap up with
this um I uh I feel better you know for
acknowledging my L's like um I don't
know that it's gonna like fix everything
like um you know but uh I feel better I
and and check this
out I had the uh steo raw.com it was
this paid subscription where like you
know I could post anything I wanted I
had no Community guidelines nud violence
like whatever you name it and uh I just
wasn't I wasn't uh coming up with enough
new like edgy stuff to really warrant
charging people a membership fee and
that was bothering me for the longest
time so I was like I got to shut it down
I got to shut it down I was thinking
that I wanted to shut it down then I
found out oh well Reddit you can put
whatever you want because I got into
Reddit I mean like like the the whole
let's talk bam Reddit like I started
checking that out like oh holy crap you
can put anything that you want on there
so I started uh steo Rod is moved to
stor.com and then I was like I I shut it
down I said hey everybody just move over
to Reddit we can I can do the same damn
thing here and nobody has to pay
anything you know which which I was
stoked on so we started the stea r stea
raw
Reddit and like now I'm like scared to
go on it because I feel like Reddit
completely turned on
me why I don't know they reddit's
mean redit it's mean I know that I can't
go in the uh the the
jackass you know uh I mean I spend some
time okay put it should be a pinned
comment in stea rot and it says let's
this party started and I and uh and in
my pinned comment I uh I talk about why
I started it and then I'm like man like
uh I I talk about taking L's in the in
the jackass sub I'm just like straight
up you know like what makes negative
comments hurt the most is when they're
true and a lot of what I read in the
jackass subreddit was true a lot of it
was [__] but uh a lot of it was true
so uh I I pledged there oh and by the
way the that the whole point of that pin
comment was to draw attention to my
narly special being 100% free that's
sick my gnarly special is 100% free
linked in my Instagram bio it's uh on
sto.com it's on Reddit and uh yeah man
you want to talk about the sick cruise
that we're going on okay we're going on
a sick
Cruise
yeah uh we're shipfaced we're going on a
cruise it's the Impractical Joker Cruise
you know I should mention this on uh
like the intro to this and um they
they've they've proposed all different
kinds of activities that I should be uh
taking part in and and I said yes to
everything sick I just want to like play
ball you know if I'm going on this
Cruise like they want me to host a belly
flop contest my answer is yes they want
me to what were the other things uh hot
sauce something contest uh bingo host
Bingo I'm in I used I used to host bingo
at a nursing home I used to volunteer to
nursing in in in early sobriety that was
my oh really yeah like um as part of
show living you had to either get a job
or you had to volunteer so many hours a
week and I was just likeo I I went to a
nursing home and then like I kept doing
it after I uh didn't have to do it
anymore that's cool yeah I was is cool
so the cruise is January 22nd to 26
Miami to Nassau Bahamas get shipfaced
cruise.com yeah that's right all right
everybody um I don't expect forgiveness
but I appreciate it but we welcome it
yeah I don't expect it but I welcome it
yeah yeah that was a good one all right
man yeah
guys now let me peel back the curtain to
leave you with this I had encouragement
from loved ones to not draw attention to
uh El's people saying dude you're a
winner man like don't do that to
yourself and I dug in my heels I said
you know what those lves were real I
really took them and I'm the kind of guy
who's going to do this I stood by it I
still do and I feel good for it to those
people who love me and who encouraged me
to preserve myself thank you I love you
back but that's how it's going to be so
with that I wish you guys uh the best
holidays and happy
everything love
you